foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with our
favorite disembodied voice from Alabama
hi everybody and of course welcome back
ladies and gentlemen TK Coleman
this week on the private podcast we told
a long story about TK's Misadventures he
had to fly to Turkey for a hair
transplant clearly it didn't take
no he actually went through hell this
last week and uh we won't dive into it
here on the public podcast but if you
want to get the details about that uh we
did a deep dive into a special kind of
Hell him going to the ER and be admitted
to the hospital for a while and this is
really his first day back anywhere uh
and we're we're so grateful you made it
back yeah man yeah man to be back we got
the rest of our team here in the studio
as well the uh Millennial minimalists
are here we're the only podcasts who
applauds for our studio audience the
future of minimalism they just had TK on
their podcast recently we'll put a link
to that in the show notes as well but
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're talking to a
listener about her shopping addiction
about being used by her family and about
finding a renewed sense of minimalism in
her life we also have a question from a
very bothered listener then our
lightning round segment and exciting
exciting announcement teaser our
documentary minimalism is now on Netflix
we'll get to the the details on that in
a moment we also have a live stream of
question for you and a listener tip but
you can check out the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 397 where we
answer five times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
segments that private podcast episode is
out right now at patreon.com the
minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck by the way if you're
on the fence patreon is now offering
free trials so if you'd like to test
drive the minimalist private podcast you
can join for seven days for free just
try it out just click the patreon link
in the description to subscribe and get
your personal link so that our weekly
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain access to
all of our podcast archives all the way
back to episode zero zero one all right
let's start with our callers if you have
a question or a comment for our show
give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcasts at the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Christy hi
my name is Christy from Opelika
and I can identify
why has felt in the past like an
alcoholic selfishness my drug
my deceased husband committed suicide
December 26
2013. he was abusive and I couldn't even
buy underwear when he was a lie I
received well I finished her and so I
started shocking to forget
I went crazy buying stuff my family also
used me to get money
I would have done anything to hang out
with my family and they knew that
so there was a little background now
daily I'm having to deal with suppressed
emotions that are extremely painful
not something I'm seeing the emptiness
in my soul I've lost family that only
wants the next dollar for me I've lost
so much that matters to me which is my
family
I'm a Believer in Christ and I feel
guilty for all the mistakes I've made
with my
what does Hillary look like how can I
ringtone and I call it the display I
have downsized an ollie own a home 950
square feet I phone donate and trashed
eighty percent of my stuff
but emotionally I'm a mess
how do I heal how can I maintain being
an anonymous
a human sleeping out another king line
wow Christy I'm so sorry to hear what
you're struggling through I I hear three
main things that I want to talk to TK
and Ryan about the first one is the
shopping addiction yeah that's one side
of it the other side of it is the family
that is using her of course you always
hear us say love people and use things
because the opposite never works but
what she's actually experiencing is the
opposite here yeah and it's not working
in fact it's draining her and it's
harming her because she's asking about
healing and so the third thing I want to
talk about is finding a renewed sense of
minimalism or Simplicity or simplifying
getting to that why why are you
simplifying your life where do you want
to start gentlemen
let me let me just first give a quick
word of encouragement to Christy and say
one I'm sorry about everything you've
been through that you described and two
just like
big kudos to you for everything that
you've done uh but with respect to that
guilt you say you feel
you say as a Christian I feel guilty and
so Christian a Christian I I say back to
you the words of the prophet Isaiah who
said come now let us reason together
though your sins be like Scarlet they
shall be as white as snow and I will
toss them into the sea of forgetfulness
if God forgets your sins your failures
and the mistakes from your past why are
you still holding on to them it all
begins with letting that go letting go
of the self-condemnation remorse is okay
remorse is when we look back on our past
and we say I did something that doesn't
reflect my values and my priorities I'm
gonna learn from that and do something
better your conscience is a tool to help
you with that but self-condemnation is
when you say because I have failed in
the past that failure is now who I am
let go of the self-condemnation learn
from the remorse and give yourself the
permission to learn and to grow and get
better it's the first thing I want to
say as the foundation
um just one second please I love this
because
we all three have different religious
spiritual beliefs right but you can find
profound wisdom in any ancient wisdom
tradition and including Christianity and
I love that you're able to connect with
with her in that way where do you want
to take it from here
yeah uh the the the loss of family when
you receive that insurance money people
start flooding into your life and and
basically being being groupies in your
life I and they they played on what you
knew was a weakness which is I I need
their validation I long for their
company and I can keep them around and
once you decided to stop playing that
game they left you and you described
that as a loss and I just want to say
first it's not a loss when the wrong
people move out of your life that's a
gain because that is for your good
secondly you lost them long before you
thought you had them you lost them
before they were coming into your life
for the money they were already gone
because they were never with you for the
right reasons when people aren't with
you for the right reasons then they're
not with you it's just an illusion and
and and and they fall away at the first
sign of of difficulty or conflict and so
I would say you are best positioned to
create space for the right kind of
people to begin flowing into your life
now when you get rid of the people that
are really just leeches they're just
there to get something from you without
giving anything back yeah yeah I uh I
love what you're talking about with the
condemnation another way to look at it
is shame so um to help her kind of uh
uh feel like she has the right to even
kind of look externally
I think that it's really important to
take care of that condemnation first so
for me like I know I've done a lot of
things that made me feel guilty I did a
lot of things and made me feel guilty up
until
um you know 29 30 years old when we
became the minimalists and I remember
when I started telling people about
minimalism they were kind of looking at
me like
oh okay okay Mr minimalist like they saw
how my lifestyle was they saw like how I
acted and who I was
um and it took years of me consistently
um behaving differently to uh start to
uh to show a different side of me and
I'll tell you it took years before I
started to feel confident enough to like
really
um feel like I was living a different
life so all that to say is Christy
in that beginning stage when you are
becoming someone different it takes a
long time before you really kind of shed
that guilt
um but hey the best way to stop feeling
guilty
is to stop doing things that make you
feel guilty and it sounds like that's
what she's doing yeah and also stop
accepting or needing the approval of
people who make you feel guilty who are
actually trying to guilt trip you right
oh yeah because that's here's the thing
you may not feel guilty on your own but
if someone keeps handing you their guilt
you should do this you're supposed to do
this for me you're not a good friend
loved one family member you're not a
good person unless you do these things
for me man that is a recipe for misery
because as soon as you help this person
you've changed yourself to help them
nothing wrong with helping other people
obviously but not at the expense of your
own well-being your own sanity your own
ability to love and I think that's the
struggle that Christy's going through
right now TK is she feels like well if I
don't do what they want me to do then it
feels unloving no it's not unloving in
fact the most loving thing that you can
do right now if someone is using you
explicitly using you is love them from a
distance that's right and people have a
way of of saying so hypocritically by
the way stop being selfish and do what I
want you to do stop being selfish by
living the life that you want to live
and start living the life that I want to
live because I'm not being selfish at
all when I say that right but you know
just because someone wants something
from you doesn't mean that it's
necessary feasible realistic or healthy
for you to be the one to give it to them
so people love to say things like you
know I I need more of this from you Ryan
I need more of this from you Josh okay I
mean man I feel scared for anybody who
uses those words with me because like if
you really need something from me you're
in trouble right because that need
doesn't translate into an obligation or
an ability on my part right but people
say that all the time but just because
someone wants or needs something from
you doesn't mean you're the best person
to be the one to give it to them and so
you've gotta let people take
responsibility for themselves and make
the choices that are healthy for you and
like Ryan said the transitions are hell
yeah the transitions are difficult
because you can't rely on those familiar
patterns those comfort those Comfort
zones of the life that you once lived
and you got to reinvent yourself
reinvent your relationships like with
our recent move for instance the social
aspect is hell when you go from like
knowing who your neighbors are always
running into people that you know you
might love the life that you're going
into but you get tested every day with
little questions like am I sure I want
to follow through on this am I sure I
made the right decision I never run into
anybody that I know I say hi to my
neighbors they looked all the way like I
have zero friends out here and it just
takes time that's not how the story ends
you can know that but you just gotta
stick with it and give yourself time to
grow into the person you're choosing to
become yeah I've had uh like family
members and Friends uh asked me for
money and I used to just give it out if
I had it and what I realized is I was
kind of setting this precedence of like
hey Ryan is the bank if you need money
he'll help you out and I had to change
the way I handled when people ask me
that question so
um I had it happen once where a family
member was like oh here's what I need
and I'm like okay I'm not doing that for
you like we we've already had this
conversation
um and they were like well you know if I
don't pay this fine then I end up in
jail and I'm like yeah I'm sorry to hear
about that like I I don't want you to be
in jail but also me giving you money is
just prolonging you helping yourself and
that's what you need your help more than
anyone else yeah and I'm happy to help
you in any other way
um but the the financial piece of it um
that's that's out of the question and
um yeah I absolutely followed through
with that and talk to that family member
show them love getting them support
um they're doing much better today uh
and I'm not taking credit for that but
uh I am saying that when you have a
family member who is trying to guilt
trip you into giving you something that
you really don't have or that isn't
going to really help them in the long
run you have every right to look at that
family member and say I'm sorry but like
that's not how I'm going to help you and
if they get upset oh you because my that
family member was like but putting it on
me you could really change my life you
could do this you could do that and I'm
like
no like it is you're you being upset I'm
sorry you're upset but this is this is
on you this is not on me I mean you can
put it on me all you want but until you
take responsibility it's gonna be hard
for you to to live a little bit of a
different life so I'm just giving her
permission here to tell her family no
but to also still be there
um for her family and in any way in any
way that she can yeah this is not how
I'm going to love you right now this is
not the best way for me to show my love
is to hand you money just like I can't
drag you kicking and screaming to
success and that's essentially what your
family member was asking you right can
you please drag me to the place in which
I'm Flawless well no because you're just
gonna drift right back to where you were
if I do all the work for you yeah
Christy I'd love to send you three
things actually because you first talked
about the shopping addiction and that is
simultaneously the easiest and most
difficult part of this question I want
help you set up some boundaries we have
a free minimalist rule book 16 rules for
loving with less you can download it for
free right now at the minimalists.com
right there on our resources page a
bunch of other free resources in there
some rules in there like the wait for it
rule if something costs more than thirty
dollars wait 30 hours what is that doing
it's adding some friction into your life
so you're staving off the impulse of
these new purchases that addiction which
is present will still be there but if
you don't act on it over time it becomes
less powerful you could append that to
when family members ask for money if
they ask you for more than thirty
dollars
wait at least 30 hours and then tell
them no right and that's all I know real
quick uh my wife and I were watching uh
John Crist is that how you say his name
comedy special last night I don't know
and anyway he said uh his nephew and his
niece were like sitting at a table and
the nephew did something to make the
niece mad and he says I'm sorry please
don't tell Mom and she says I'll forgive
you for five dollars and uh I feel like
when you give people money in order to
keep them from being mad at you that's
exactly what you're doing you're playing
a game like that people are basically
saying hey I'll like you for a hundred
dollars yeah I won't be mad at you for a
50 loan or whatever it may be and if you
play that game you can never get out of
that game it just makes it hard to
escape it later yeah two other things I
have for you Christy a lot of people use
things our book obviously we've been
talking about that during this episode
what's happening right now is you are
being used by people and that can also
turn you into someone who uses other
people if you see it demonstrated Enough
by other people what happens you start
to take on those behaviors and so our
book love people use things if you enjoy
the podcast I think you'll enjoy the
audiobook version Ryan and I recorded
that audio book together and then
finally some great news we're going to
expand on this later during the right
here right now segment I'm going to
encourage you to go back and watch our
first documentary it's called minimalism
a documentary about the important things
and it just came out on YouTube
yesterday it's getting its third life
after it's theatrical release it's
Netflix release 80 million people sold
it on Netflix and now it is finally
available on YouTube youtube.com the
minimalist or you can find it over at
minimalism.com as well our next question
is from Lane
hi my name is Lane and I'm calling from
Los Angeles I heard you mentioned on
your consumerism show that one of you
had stayed in an Airbnb while you were
visiting Seattle I found that
interesting because on one hand I think
it's cool that average people are able
to make a little money uh extra money
renting out their spaces but on the
other hand services like Airbnb are
destroying neighborhoods in cities such
as San Francisco and make it impossible
for residents to find affordable housing
as well as affecting Community
communities in a negative fashion for
example how would you feel if you had
bought or rented a home in a community
that you carefully vetted only to find
out that you now have you know very few
actual neighbors around you instead you
have a revolving door of strangers that
are staying there
um
the same goes for their sharing economy
services that appeal to you know
Millennials such as Uber and Lyft that
are acting outside of the rules
regulations and safety codes to everyone
else in those Industries have to follow
I have a friend actually that says it's
not really so much a sharing economy as
they share cropping economy for example
Uber is building their business on the
backs of their drivers who aren't
considered employees and get no benefits
or protections and will eventually
become obsolete as Uber is investing a
ton of dough in self-driving cars
obviously part of reducing consumerism
is a desire to be more ethical in your
shopping or habits so how do you square
up the lack of Ethics in these
businesses with your desire to say have
you know a cool place to stay when
you're traveling or a ride that you can
hire at the touch of the nap
Lane sounds really bothered by some
things and TK I have a whole rant that I
want to go on here
about being bothered because I see
myself yeah in fact I me too I dated
someone like Lane who was bothered by
almost everything and
it brought it out in me because I am
bothered by almost everything I have OCD
and so I think by Nature I'm sort of
bothered but you can talk can you talk
about some of these services that might
be bothering her Tica yeah you know I
think Scott Barry Kaufman Dr Scott Barry
Kaufman
um had a really great uh tweet storm a
few days ago where he talked about the
need for more yes and in politics he
says most discussions now are so
oversimplified that it's either you
believe problems are systemic or you
believe individual agency exist and
there is no having both so if you ever
say there are some things that are
within your locus of control that you
ought to focus on you are an enemy of
the belief that some problems are
structural in nature and if you affirm
that some problems are structural in
nature you're an enemy of the belief
that we are ever personally responsible
for anything in our lives and it's
actually a little bit of both it is the
nature of problems that every problem
problem has a systemic Dimension and a
personal Dimension no exceptions to this
if there's a problem there are elements
way beyond our control lots of moving
parts that are contributing to the
emergence and experience of that problem
and there are also some things we can do
to have agency over how we react and
respond and so the thing we have to ask
ourselves whenever we're observing all
these sort of systemic problems that are
annoying us is okay what's going to be
your personal relationship to what you
do about the systemic things because
that's what it comes down to how are you
personally going to fight
fight that educate yourself about that
Empower others to do things about it and
each person has to answer that question
for themselves the second part however
which does not require a denial of the
first part is how can I make sure that
my preoccupation with these systemic
things doesn't become paralyzing when it
comes down to the everyday choices I've
got to make for me and my family because
we've got to get up and live our lives
even though there will be people out
there exploiting others taking advantage
of others every single day and if I have
to wait until someone comes along and
solves all the systemic things and
eliminates all the exploitation before I
can do productive and constructive
things I'm going to be in trouble and
all the people who depend on me are
going to be in trouble as well and so I
I don't say ignore these issues
um I don't say pretend like they don't
exist I don't say deny them but I do say
don't let them prevent you from making
the healthy choices you need to make to
move on with your life because a part of
what we have to do in life is learn how
to play the game in spite of the fact
that there are other participants in the
game who are definitely breaking the
rules that we ourselves are committed to
not breaking and that's the top
challenging thing yeah yeah I mean yeah
it's it's putting it on yourself as much
as you can like that's I mean that's
what I do with like homelessness for
example in Los Angeles drives me crazy
like it's sad so many freaking homeless
people so it's like a piece of me wants
to
um
you know uh participate in out in
recreational outrage on Twitter and talk
about how you know whatever or you know
our mayor isn't doing anything and it's
these all of these people right exactly
right and unfortunately I used I used to
do that and that recreational outrage it
almost feels like you're doing something
because you feel like you're supporting
something but you're really not I I
really wasn't doing anything with the
recreational outrage but let me tell you
what I what I do let me ask you a
question could you argue that maybe you
were doing less than nothing I I could
probably find an argument for that
absolutely so here's what I do I will
um when I'm out and about and a homeless
person asks me for something which
happens every day in La
um there are times where I am compelled
to be like oh like this person legit
needs something to like make their day a
little better and I will go out of my
way to do what I can um this there's a
dude standing outside one of the um uh
gas stations and I could just see like
need some help and I'm like what do you
need man I like pull out a five dollar
bill he's like I don't even want he's
like I just want food man I'm like okay
cool I was like I will go in and get you
some food so I like went in and bought
them I don't know some really bad junk
food that TK can't eat anymore it wasn't
TK asking me for the food
but like I went out of my way to like
just here's the one thing I can do that
is much uh that is much more than um
going on to Twitter and being like uh
pointing the finger and saying all of
you should feel bad for the way this is
and then me just like doing this and
getting off of Twitter and be like well
I did my part today yeah I think you
bring up a really great point that
you can do something even if it doesn't
fix the problem in totality permanently
yes and I think that's what we're
looking for is like unless the thing
that I do contributes to fixing the
problem in a permanent nature I have an
abiding cure for it then I will just
throw my hands up and do nothing we make
a binary way too way too often it
doesn't have to be one or the other I
mean Lane's question is kind of like
either you're for or you're against it
and here's why I'm against it
um so what do you think are you for or
against it and it's like I'm neither for
nor against it as much as like it is a
um it's a business that exists and a lot
of people
um they can't get to work without Uber
um I mean there's they can't have a job
without Uber like I know people who who
use that too I mean I know she was kind
of talking about the employees and how
they're ripped off I know a lot of
people who um drive for Uber and like
it's kind of their Saving Grace when it
comes to making that supplemental income
that they need to make to uh especially
again in Los Angeles oh yeah but here's
the thing too
cognitive dissonance is we all have it
we all have it uh if you use a computer
you are uh technically supporting a
child slave labor
um that's how the computers get made so
you know if you look at anything deep
enough
um you're going to find a reason to
stand up against it so again this is
just me uh just giving another reason as
to why it's not about like you know
um uh whatever land-basting these
companies it is figuring out what I Ryan
Nicodemus could do on a daily basis to
maybe um help combat that or
add some kind of value to the people who
are getting value taken away from them
and I want to just take that a little
bit further the one thing that I can do
is I can be less bothered Lane compelled
me to write something yesterday as I was
listening to this question you know I
sit down and I write every day and I
wrote something that I think most people
will understand I just called it
bothered if you look for reasons to be
bothered you'll find them guaranteed
look I get it you're angry you're bitter
you're bothered by something that
happened by something that someone did
or said if you look for reasons to be
bothered
you will find them but the same is true
with gratitude if you look for reasons
to be grateful you'll find those too
the difference is bitterness holds you
back
gratitude allows you to let go
so you can move forward in fact
who told you that the things that bother
you
are bothersome
are you supposed to be bothered by those
things maybe
maybe not
yes what happened was unfair what's
happening right now is unfair life is
unfair
who told you it's supposed to be fair
okay
so maybe you've been wronged
maybe you've been victimized
how long are you going to cling to your
victimhood
playing the victim brings anybody a
temporary feeling of self-righteous
certainty
but the same self-righteousness
is the same thing that will keep you
mired in a pool of discontent to be
clear this is not some rant about why
you should be more optimistic I am not a
blind optimist
because forcing yourself to be positive
forcing yourself to be positive doesn't
work
but seeing the positive and any less
than ideal situation even amid a sea of
terrible Injustice
takes less effort than clinging to the
perceived negatives
just ask this Victor Frankel
just ask Victor Frankel if he could do
it from a concentration camp
so can you or
you can create your own
concentration camp
one that is built with the disempowering
stories you cling to
this is one of the many reasons I love
my wife
she's no Pollyanna
she doesn't pretend that everything is
perfect she accepts things as they are
but she doesn't look for excuses to be
bothered
consequently she's probably the happiest
person I know
and she's a role model for letting go of
negativity that doesn't serve anyone so
how long are you going to cling to being
bothered because the longer you cling
the farther you're going to get dragged
yeah energy flows where attention goes
and you get to decide where you're
putting your attention yeah yeah and
this isn't a dissertation toward Lane
what I'm saying is Lane I see myself in
use when I'm asking you these questions
I'm really asking my weakest self these
questions because I have that tendency
to be bothered and so when I ask you
about how long are you going to cling to
being bothered that is a question I have
to ask myself all the time yeah often
refer back to some of the stoics shout
out to the to Ryan holiday and the the
daily stoic but um I brought some quotes
here Marcus Aurelius says don't be
overheard complaining even to yourself
and isn't that what happens we had Dr
John deloney on the podcast a few weeks
ago and he told that story of like any
time he's complaining even to himself
where he's creating these narratives in
his head his wife will determ yo nope
nope
I've started incorporating that even
into my own life as soon as a
disempowering story I can't believe she
did this I can't believe he did that I
can't believe they did that nope
and shut that whole conversation down
right away that internal conversation
here's another one from Marcus Aurelius
you always own the option of not having
an opinion you always own the option of
having no opinion there is never any
need to be worked up or troubled
or to trouble your soul about things you
can't control these things are not
asking to be judged by by you leave them
alone
so you always have the option the power
of having no opinion about a thing we're
in a culture now especially with social
media where we are required to have an
opinion about something and everything I
must stand on this side of the issue or
this side of the issue right
it's uh well like there's only two sides
too it's like right and that's the
problem yeah and when I walk down the
aisle in the middle everyone wants to
throw things at me from both sides how
can you you must be left wing or right
wing or you must be this or that
whatever it might be right and it's like
well no I don't pick a side Naval
ravacant talks about how if you if your
beliefs perfectly conform to any
ideology or political party
that means you're not a clear thinker
you're not thinking for yourself if you
can take all of your beliefs and then
just hand them to a political party what
happened is actually they handed you
your beliefs all of your beliefs are
memetic beliefs I have two more quotes
for you this one is really short it's
from Epictetus it's not things that
upset us but our judgment about things
that upsets us I thought she was quoting
a rapper for a minute epic Titus I'm
like who's epic that's good yeah well I
do have a quote here from the stoic
philosopher Beyonce
she said don't talk about it be about it
and that's really what Ryan was talking
about earlier or epicsetus may have put
it a bit more poetically when he said
don't put on errors about your
self-improvement yeah don't talk about
it be about it
doesn't mean that we can't say something
we can't speak up but merely speaking up
and not taking any sort of action it's
just words in the wind yeah yeah you
know you know one thing I will say is
that
I don't always hold other people to the
standards that I hold myself to
because we all come at things from
different backgrounds different Vantage
points and different priorities and so
when it comes to people who complain to
me part of my MO is I allow everyone the
grace to tell whatever narrative they
tell about their life without contesting
them on that narrative so if a friend
comes to me and their narrative is the
universe is totally unfair to me I have
it harder than everybody else
I allow them the grace of sand that's
that's your narrative I'm not here to
play Devil's Advocate with that
narrative I'm not here to argue you into
how much better your life actually is or
a dismiss your problem is not being a
big deal at all it's that's your
narrative I'm here to hear you out with
empathy
however
what I will try to do if I consider
myself a friend is to ask you where do
you want to go with that from here is
your goal to get me to also tell the
same narrative about my life is that is
that what the end game is is that why
we're having the conversation you tell
me what you need is the goal to help you
figure out how to contend with or fight
against whatever it is you condemn or is
the goal to help you figure out how to
cultivate whatever it is you love you
tell me what that goal is and maybe we
can have a conversation about that but
at the end of the day your narrative is
your narrative and so I'm not mad at
anybody out there who's mad if you're
frustrated with systems and you hate
Uber and you're like pissed off at
Airbnb I'm never going to be the dude to
tell you that I don't think you should
be pissed off at Airbnb but you're also
not the one affirming it right well yeah
well I have the right to be honest and
say I'm not pissed off by whatever it is
that pisses you off I have that right I
love what you're saying because what TK
is saying is hey look um I support you
feeling the way you feel and that's
about all you can do because people are
allowed to feel however they feel and
giving them permission and accepting
them and seeing them like that's
beautiful but then he's drawn the line
and saying hey um you can feel that way
but that doesn't mean I have to feel
that way right and sometimes I will feel
the same way as you and even then that
can't do a whole lot for you so yeah I
hate the Airbnb guys too I personally
happen to be annoyed with them as well
but uh what does that get us I mean
depending how much you value me maybe
that validates your opinion hey TK Cohen
agrees with me all right now we got two
people pissed off at things that piss us
off but what do we do like how do we
fight against that not not because your
emotions are not important but because
your feelings are so important that we
don't want them to die as feelings alone
we want them to be channeled into
constructive action that's creatively
expressed we want to bring forth some
Beauty from those feelings and I think
the best place to start is from a place
of acceptance right yes there are some
things I can't change and I know that
you have this narrative that Airbnb is
evil and other people have this uh this
notion that Airbnb is outstanding it
Harkens back to we had Andrew Schultz on
the podcast a long time ago and he had
this little throwaway line it is and it
isn't I think that is true in any
situation that is complex it is and it
isn't and yes you can be bothered by it
but if we're not going to do anything
with that bother other than throw our
hands up then I might as well go ahead
and let go of the bother because that's
not doing anything for me yeah either
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
during the lightning round we each have
60 seconds to answer your questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
over at the minimalists.com so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like today's
question is from Homer I just recently
watched your video of Dr John deloney's
wife telling him he has enough after he
got new speaking opportunities he wanted
why can't she just say congratulations
or I'm proud of you let me give you some
context here this video really blew up
three four five million views all over
the place oh wow people were really
upset and I found especially guys were
very upset oh my goodness John deloney's
wife wow
and so it seems to me that they really
missed the point in that video Dr
deloney basically said hey I was going
through really difficult times and I
would psych myself up by getting more
work and what would happen is she heard
a moment ago she heard me devastated
like oh I'm so overwhelmed I'm so busy
my life is out of control and then a
moment later what happened
he she heard him shouting for joy in the
basement because
he got another speaking gig another
opportunity and what she was trying to
illustrate is I want you to understand
that we already have enough and if you
want to do this wonderful but if you
don't want to do it realize you're not
doing this for me and our family you're
doing it for you and that's okay yeah so
I got something pithy for you my pithy
answer is it's offensive to get offended
on behalf of people who are not offended
that offends me
I think
gondoloni was not offended but a lot of
people got offended that his wife would
talk to him this way yeah but he was
actually thankful for it so it's another
layer of offensive to be like hey you
shouldn't be thankful for that TK you
should also be offended on my behalf
well no I choose not to be offended and
if you want to be offended go ahead and
be offended I'm not going to hold on to
it yeah let's give TK Coleman 60 seconds
on the clock
beware the friend who can't say
what is it what do you got here you're
not okay yeah
so let me say it again beware the friend
who can't say you're not okay uh you
know I I don't think a good friend is
somebody who should force themselves to
be happy for you no matter what right
um they they could support your mission
but still question your method they can
advocate for your well-being without
treating you like you could never
possibly be wrong sometimes support it
takes the form of saying hey
congratulations good job I'm so happy
for you but sometimes support takes the
form of hey man I'm a little bit
concerned to me the real privilege of
friendship is that the context of our
already established love makes it
possible for me to challenge you and get
away with that in ways that other people
can't anybody can get away with feeding
your ego a complete stranger can say wow
you look great and get away with that a
friend is someone that can get away with
sand a let me play Devil's Advocate with
that idea hey I'm a little concerned
about this hey I have a problem with
what you just said and how you said it
because the two of you can talk things
out in a way where you can get to the
bottom of it without your love for one
another being questioned so support
isn't always about congratulations
sometimes it's about challenging yeah
yeah ladies and gentlemen Ryan Nicodemus
makes me think how uh When someone tells
me I got something in my teeth when I
actually do have something in my teeth
I'm like oh you and I could be friends
I think this might work out oh yeah
because a real friend is going to say
something like that uh my pit the answer
is this
if you think love is risky just wait
until you find out how risky it is to
avoid love
here's the thing when you get into a
relationship especially a romantic
long-term committed relationship
um you have to be prepared to risk that
relationship and if you're not prepared
to risk that relationship you may not be
prepared for that long-term committed
relationship the last thing I want is
Mariah to
um hold some resentment towards me uh
and and not even let me know what she's
upset about for the sake of just going
with the flow we all know what happens
when you go with the flow you end up at
The Falls so Mariah and I have an
agreement if something bothers us we
make sure to say something because we
don't want to hold that in because we do
love each other and we love each other
so much that we can have a mature
conversation without feeling like one of
us is is being controlled or overlooked
by the other I love that if you think
love is risky just wait until you find
out how risky it is to avoid love and I
think that applies not just to Intimate
Relationships it certainly applies there
but it applies to a friendship it
applies to a stranger to love someone is
to see them for who they are and what
happens when we get offended by someone
we try to change them you I'm going to
convince you that I'm right and you're
wrong and there's no risk in in
well there is risk in that right but
it's much more risky to sit back and
actually see someone yeah for who they
are because you might realize something
about yourself you know by the way this
reaction to John deloney's story just
goes to show you like
how many amazing life-changing
conversations have we all had one-on-one
with somebody who questioned us or
challenged Us in an important way think
about how confusing and overwhelming and
stressful and toxic it would be if that
conversation were broadcasted on the
internet for everyone to express their
opinion about it oh my goodness man
you know you'd lose so much value I'm so
thankful that there are conversations
that still happen in private one-on-one
without the internet telling us what we
think about it and I understand the
Oddity like he chose to share that story
none of us are victims here I totally
get it but it just kind of makes me
think about in healthy relationships you
got to be okay with the fact that this
relationship is good because what we're
doing is good for you and I yeah and
other people aren't gonna be good with
the way that you and I do good but what
matters is that you and I are good with
it yeah and honestly like delony's wife
uh it really seems like this is a loving
act on her part like how difficult is it
for her to go to him and say hey you
know what like I just want to make this
observation about everything that just
transpired she didn't even tell him what
to do yeah yeah right the easy thing is
to be like oh congratulations like
that's the easy thing to do the tough
thing and what someone would do uh and I
hope Mariah would do with me or or Josh
or teak or anyone in the studio it's
like if you have a problem with me or if
you see that see something that I'm not
seeing please say something like that's
that is so valuable man and that's all
that is loving especially because she
simply made as Ryan said an observation
yeah and that is important and TK you
bring up a great point if we live
streamed all of our intimate
conversations
and allowed people to comment on it I
think it would radically change our we'd
be afraid to love someone because of the
backlash we might get that's that that
said I did live stream TK's entire
hospital today it's only available on
our patreon yeah that was uh that wasn't
Michelle that was Josh with the VHS live
streaming it so when I when I say
risking relationship do you guys know
what that does that resonate with you at
all go for it so to risk a relationship
is to go to someone and deliver them a
truth at at the potential cost of that
relationship changing yes and what I'll
say is that if we don't risk
relationships especially with the people
that we love as much as you know deloney
and his wife love each other or their
kids for that matter if we if we're not
willing to risk that relationship like
that is I don't know what's worse like
um risking the relationship or holding
on to this resentment and never saying
anything if I'm too scared to risk the
relationship regardless though the
relationship is being risked you might
as well do it in a genuine way that's
such a great point we're gonna check in
with the patreon live stream here in a
moment so patrons drop your questions
and comments in the chat we already have
a few lined up but first real quick for
right here right now here is one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist some exciting and new brand
new news y'all we're calling it renewed
minimalism this episode right because
our first documentary minimalism a
documentary about the important things
is getting a third life yeah yeah after
being the number one documentary in
theaters in 2016 we did in fact I hadn't
seen the film since it was in theaters
in 2016. I just rewatched it recently
I'm going to talk to you about that and
also got 80 million plus views on
Netflix seven years on Netflix
minimalism is now on YouTube youtube.com
the minimalist that just came out
yesterday June 18th and we had that
theatrical release which I learned a
whole lot Ryan learned a whole lot from
that 2016. we went to Netflix they were
the only big streamer at the time
there's some others like CSO I think was
still around but it wasn't all of these
other streamers we went to Netflix and
said hey can you would you be willing
would you like this documentary and
they're like no no it doesn't really fit
what we're doing okay well we're the
minimalists we always do these things on
our own right we've been doing these
huge tours and writing books and doing
everything when there were just two
people showing up and now there are more
people showing up we didn't have the
podcast at the time we just had the blog
and some books and so we said we'll put
it out in theaters how hard can that be
well turns out really really difficult
and uh everyone has their hand in the
cookie jar when you do that 400 Theaters
U.S Canada Australia and we had a really
wildly successful theatrical release and
I say that now
because it was the number one Indie dock
in theaters in 2016 which sounds really
impressive to realize when the hell was
the last time I went to go see a
documentary in a theater right and the
truth is that yeah a lot of people went
to go see in theaters but not nearly as
many uh as people who sold online so we
went back to Netflix after theatrical he
said look we did it look how awesome
this was and they're like uh you didn't
hear no the first time and we're like oh
no I guess we didn't okay yeah we'll go
put it on our own so we put it out a
transactional video so uh iTunes and
Amazon and uh Vimeo and Google Play
store and it was available online our
audience went out and supported it so
much so that it became really popular on
iTunes it was the number one film on
iTunes uh that first month that it came
out online and that's when Netflix came
back to us and they were like hey uh you
know that whole documentary thing can we
get the streaming rights to it and so we
said sure and they got the English
rights and then it went it it just
really took off on Netflix and they got
the international rights and they
re-upped and then seven years minimalism
was on Netflix and over 80 million views
over there a lot of people saw it a lot
of people heard this message for the
first time in fact if you do a Google
Trends search on the word minimalism
December 2016 when it hit Netflix all of
a sudden
I'm parabolic it was it was this huge
increase and I went back recently for
the first time in years and watched the
film because I was trying to tweeze out
I gotta find like five or six different
tick tocks so we can promote the film on
social media right and let people know
that it's getting a third life on the
minimalist YouTube channel by the way
100 advertisement free still yeah and so
no advertisements on our YouTube channel
either and we just wanted to put it out
there because we finally got the rights
back to the film and we said okay we
have the rights now we want to get it in
front of more eyeballs we're not going
to make any money from putting on
YouTube but we're gonna reach more
people if we put it out on YouTube and
so I went to Matt diabella got the film
rewatched it looked for about six
different tick tocks and it turns out
matthewvella invented Tick Tock I
believe that I believe that the film is
put together in one minute chunks I
never realized that but I mean literally
a lot of the the the clips I pulled out
79 minute film I found 80 tick tocks in
the film now I'm not going to say we're
gonna put out all 80 of those but there
are 80 clips that could certainly just
make it and they're they are influential
they are effective on their own but then
when you piece them all together he
created a masterpiece of a film dude
he's a savant when it comes to directing
but even more so when it comes to
editing hey they don't call him the
Italian Stallion for no reason man
do you think I just made that up
so you can watch it right now on the
minimalist YouTube channel or at
minimalism.com our side project is
called minimalism life we have the
domain minimalism.com so if you're just
looking for an easy place to look for it
and share it minimalism.com share it
with someone who you think tag someone
who you think will get value from this
film if you've seen it you want to
re-watch it now it was a great
opportunity to do so for free 100
percent
advertisement free let's check in with
the patreon live stream Alabama what do
you got for us Catherine had a question
will the bonus content for the
minimalism documentary still be
available to purchase what a great
question yes it will uh if you want
there's six so here's the other problem
we had 79 minute film but we we filmed
about a thousand hours of footage yeah
now most of that was Ryan and Matt
looking at sunsets and time lapse
sunrises wow I can't help it man I'm a
sucker for a sunset he and Matt had the
most romantic year in 2014. oh my
goodness I don't think I've ever
deliberately watched that many sunsets
with someone like because we did watch a
lot it was in the most beautiful places
we've been like Santa Fe New Mexico and
it's just stunning there so a lot of
what you see in the film the sunset
sunrise the time lapse things the stars
in Nevada that's all Matt and Ryan
hanging out just watching the stars for
a while and filming it setting up a
tripod and waiting for many hours but
also so we filmed a lot of interviews
many interviews that didn't make the
film or extended versions of like Sam
Harris in the film for like four minutes
but we've interviewed him for an hour or
Dan Harris we interviewed him for an
hour Patrick Rohn interviewed him for an
hour or two and all of those interviews
six hours of additional interviews we
have over at
minimalismfilm.com Professor Sean will
put a link to that in the show notes as
well let's do one more live stream I'm
trying to think who I'm trying to think
who's in that bonus footage that we
really wanted to make in the film but
they couldn't make it in the film but
they are in the is I'm thinking like
crew Spence maybe or yeah uh we had
Andrew Clifford capener who did the
music for the film we did a stunning a
beautiful beautiful interview with him
yes in this like Quonset hut house and
is All Steel and it was a stunning
minimalist and he's really really
attractive to he's a very handsome man
it just didn't fit the film yeah and
that happened there were some amazing
interviews it simply didn't fit the film
so yeah minimalismfilm.com if you want
to check those out here's a question
that came from Bridget what are your
thoughts on how the death of a parent
affects one's identity hmm TK
you have both your parents thankfully
see Brian you have both of your parents
thankfully yeah I've heard this phrase
that you don't know who you are as a
human or you don't become an adult until
you've lost both of your parents and I
don't know that that's completely true
but I think there's an essence of that
where yes you realize like oh I'm sort
of in it all alone now there's no one
here to take care of me anymore I grew
up in a pretty chaotic home so there
wasn't someone to take care of me for a
really long time and so I think I
developed into an adult much sooner than
that but I can see where we have a
dependence on someone and even as a
psychological dependence when that
tether is untethered all of a sudden
there's a freedom there but there's also
an uncertainty created by that yeah
yeah you know I I think each
relationship in some ways is is kind of
defined by the unique things that those
people invoke from one another and so
when you lose someone period you lose
those aspects of yourself I think about
my best friend EJ who I lost at 21. it's
like there's just a certain way he made
me laugh that I'll never laugh again and
and it's not out of sheer determination
it's not a refusal it's just that he's
not here to provoke that particular
brand of laughter from me and so we lose
parts of ourselves when we lose people
because of that in some kind of way but
I've never uh lost my parents and and if
and if you have to lose them to become a
complete human being I hope I never
become a complete human being you know I
love them so much man and uh I'm super
super passionate about
you know being able to to look at a
question and say I'm not worthy to
answer that one I don't have the
experience I don't have the hard-earned
wisdom to say anything about how it
affects a person to lose their parents
I've got some close friends who've gone
through that and I've never tasted that
yeah and um
God God help me if if that day were to
come for me yeah makes me think of a
couple things first
um I'm gonna call my Mom after this
podcast yeah yeah I was gonna call her
after this podcast you know what man
I'll tell her I'll try to call you when
I'm done wait wait
TJ's done
[Laughter]
we'll call your mom too
uh man so you know I got my parent I got
to appreciate him as much as I can um
the second thing is uh man how grateful
I am that they taught me to to count on
myself and not count on them because I
think that's where a lot of maybe the
um the identity changes is when you rely
on your parents so much for whatever it
is it may not be
you know um anything you maybe it's just
support you know someone you can call
and get some support on when you're
feeling down and then when you don't
have that now yeah I can imagine it'd be
like an identity crisis oh no who do I
call now who's gonna support me now yeah
it goes back to the it is and it isn't
when my mom died it was one of the worst
things that happened to me it was also
one of the best things that happened to
me none of us would be here in this room
right now if she had lived when she died
it made me question everything when you
get into some sort of accident or crash
in life you have this moment and you get
to decide how am I going to course
correct from here and for me it opened
up a whole bunch of other questions what
is truly important in my life who's the
person I want to become how am I going
to redefine success why have I given
meaning to all these material
possessions what's truly important in my
life I'd never asked those questions
before and so I followed this path and I
realized the path I was headed down
the destination was misery was
discontent and by the way the path was
also paved with subtle miseries and
subtle discontents and my mom's death
while it was awful and I never wanted
that to happen I certainly did become a
different person after that and the
reason I did she I thank her for that
even today because she helped me ask
those questions her death helped me ask
those questions that got me off of that
path and helped me create my own path
we're gonna check back in with the
patreon live stream here in a little bit
but first Alabama what else you got for
us I gotta call mama bama but also
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners hi my name's Karen I'm
calling from Hertfordshire in the UK
I'm calling with some tips today for
anyone who's been through bereavement
recently it's a tough thing to go
through and you sort of still have to
deal with all the objects that are left
behind and that's been quite a difficult
process for me number one tip is
remembering that the love is not in the
object the love you have for that person
is not on the object and that's a thing
that I've heard before on the podcast
but it's been my little motto for
dealing with this my father passed away
in January and I've had a lot of objects
and things to go through of here so I've
just been saying that over and over to
myself and it's been very very helpful
my love for him is in the things I did
for him when he was alive the times I
told him I loved him and in my memories
that I carry with me for the rest of my
life number two and this wouldn't be for
everyone is that I've chosen to make a
memory bear out of some of his old
clothing you can just find online if you
Google memory there there's lots of
different companies I've gone with one
in the UK called Lily's love that I
found on Facebook but not just for
bereaved People's Clothing also they can
make wedding dresses Bears out of
wedding dresses Bears out of old baby
slaving so if your children have grown
up it's another good thing that you
could think about doing with the clothes
the third thing is just remembering the
greatest object my parents could
bequeath me is me my flesh my blood they
chose to raise me and that's an amazing
gift the gift of life and it's really
important that I hang on to that I was a
surprise baby so they didn't have to
have me but they carried on and I know
parents aren't always brilliant they
don't always make the best choices but
they chose to try they chose to try and
raise me well and I know that I only
honor that gift if I spend the time now
looking after myself as I live my life
rather than pressing over some old
Crockery or CDs so I hope those pets
help someone I'm sending out my love to
anyone who's going through the same
experience at the moment
all right y'all that is our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 397 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
why is hidden clutter the most toxic
form of clutter why are you guys so
against storage bins what's wrong with
you Ryan well that's the question I have
been asking myself that for 41 years now
how can we avoid shame from others while
downsizing plus a million more questions
for the minimalists also this week a
private minimalist home tour one of our
listeners minimalist bathrooms plus much
much more of less if you want to hear
all that check out the minimalist
private podcast on patreon just click
the link in the description remember you
can try it for a week for free and if
you still haven't made up your mind
here's a testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon supporters Michael says I
have listened to your podcast for the
last three years and I I'm not gonna lie
I am not a minimalist but your podcast
has changed my life I literally listened
to your podcast every time I mow the
lawn no one knows why push Mo a 1.2 acre
lot that's amazing
my neighbors stare at me I wonder why it
takes so long honestly I have a riding
mower but I'd rather use my push mower
because it allows me to listen to your
private podcast including all of the
archives it's the only time in my
chaotic week that I feel at peace wow
Michael what a testimonial that's huge
yeah uh so big all right y'all if you
leave here today with just one message
please let it be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you
every little